[Music]
hello and welcome to everyone who is
starting to join us
my name is will torres i'm one of the
admission officers at the stanford
graduate school of business
so excited for you to join us we have
two amazing guests
i like to think of them as icons on
campus especially when it comes to
the work behind what's been happening
with diversity equity and inclusion
here at the gsb so i'm going to let them
introduce themselves
what's going to happen is i have a
couple of questions for them
from there we're just going to have some
discussion and open it up to q a box so
as you start to come up with questions
or things
that you wanna like inquire um go ahead
and pop that in there we're happy to
help evolve the conversation
so with that um sarah could you please
introduce yourself
maybe your name your role and what
inspires you to this work
terrific thank you will and welcome
everybody i'm so excited to be part of
this panel
with my colleagues will and lori and i'm
excited to meet some of you
virtually and to see where you're all
coming in from
so i am a professor here at the graduate
school of business in the organizational
behavior
group but i'm also serving as the senior
associate dean
for academic affairs so i'm one of the
dean's leadership team
and i'm in that role i oversee our
diversity equity and inclusion efforts
with my collaborators such as will and
lori and some of the other folks that
you've had a chance to meet this week
and when i think about what inspires me
about this work
and i think i can sum it up pretty
easily by saying
that at the gsb what we want to do is to
train
principled and purposeful leaders who
are going to make meaningful
and i'm going to add positive change in
the world
and as we work on these efforts at the
school what we hope is that we are going
to be able to inspire
our students inspire our staff inspire
our faculty our alums
to to join us in these efforts and
by this doing this together we can make
positive change in the world and to me
that's inspiring lori
thank you so much sarah my name is
laurie mackenzie and i am the lead
strategist for diversity equity
inclusion here at stanford gsb
and i come from a corporate background
so prior to
coming here i worked at companies like
procter gamble
and apple and ebay and in part that's
what
inspires me for this work the most
amazing leaders i've seen
who have been very um agile
who can think deeply about what both
customers want and what their internal
employees want
those great leaders have cared
deeply about the diversity equity and
inclusion in their organizations so
what inspires me is that this work that
we do
is contributing to better leadership
better and organizations and
and to your point sarah hopefully
positive change that benefits
everybody oh lori you also hold
a dif you also wear a different hat on
campus can you tell us a little bit
about that too
please absolutely i am thanks will for
saying that i also co-founded
the stanford vmware women's leadership
innovation lab
which makes my title i think the longest
title it never fits
on a line anywhere and what we do
is we do the research in organizations
for inclusion
and we have an affiliates program where
60 companies like
big ones like google facebook schwab
join
in order to benefit from our research
but to also inform our research
and again i get to work with sarah
because sarah is one of the faculty
sponsors of that organization so our
worlds
across campus truly are intertwined nice
thank you
yeah i wanted to make sure that folks
knew like so much is happening in the
space and
even as we think about where we are
today
a lot of the work that we've been doing
at the gsb kind of takes us back a few
years
um last year 2019 we published the first
dei report
um but even in the steps to get there oh
there was
um there was progress that was happening
so maybe sarah
and laurie as kind of some of our
leaders on this front can
what brought us to the dei report what
inspired it
can you tell us a little bit about that
please sure i can start and then lori
you can jump in and piggyback on some of
the things that i
have to say and i think that um
the the it's important to sort of
recognize something that
is actually important to understand
about the school and that is
until dean john levin had taken over
as the dean of the school there hadn't
been a dean who had decided that
uh that he or she needed to have and
actually in this case it's all he
but that he needed to have um one of his
leadership team members overseeing
diversity equity and inclusion
so that itself was a big step and i have
to say you know
in some ways shocking that the business
school hadn't done that before
now that wasn't to say that the deans
weren't interested in this because they
were
but they hadn't they had they have sort
of taken a different approach which was
a lot less
um i guess a lot less centralized
although it's still pretty decentralized
here which is part of our part of
the way we have set this up but that
itself was really important and
as i took over the reins and took over
that role
one of the things that i wanted to do
was to spend a lot of time
really taking a design thinking like
approach to this and
one of the areas that i do teach when i
am teaching is design thinking
particularly thinking about design
thinking um as it might apply within
organizations to improve organizations
and
and often around diversity equity
inclusion and belonging
so i began that process by spending
about 18 months
talking and listening and i want to
emphasize mostly listening and answering
questions
and talking to staff members at the gsb
staff members across campus faculty all
over campus alums
students of course all of our student
bodies in
the mba students the msx students
executive education participants phd
students
and and trying to understand exactly
what was being done
where i was really lucky because there
are a lot of passionate people at the
gsb
who work and we're working on diversity
topics equity topics
inclusion topics and it was there was a
a wonderful sort of informal working
group that was working together on these
topics and so i was able to get a lot of
information
fairly quickly and that led up to the
beginning of
the um report and at about that time
and i'll i'll kind of hand the baton
over to lori that's when
i decided that we really needed at the
gsb a lead strategist to help us
think about how to structure that report
somebody who had spent a lot of time
at like lori doing work in companies
doing work at the university and
understanding
all of the different landscapes and and
thinking about what we might want to
put in the report and also importantly
how we might want to think strategically
about what we wanted to do going forward
because
you know with the report and i hope
you'll get a chance to read it and and
laurie and i
and our team are finishing up the the
2020 version right now it's being
you know designed and formatted so
that's exciting
and a shout out to a lot of folks like
will who have given us
feedback along the way but um one of the
things that we do in the report is talk
about what we've done
but spend a lot of time talking about
what we need to do and what we want to
do going forward and so i knew that i
needed some help with that
and at that time i brought laurie on
first in a consulting role and then
eventually we were able to convince her
to um to come on in the lead
lead strategist role so lori i'll i'll
hand it over to you and see if you
wanted to add anything to the lead up to
the dei report the first one
you know i love what you said sarah
because there was already so much good
work
happening and i think one of the
outcomes of the report
is those sparks of great dei work
moved from being a spark into a lasting
program
that we're now able to evaluate how
we're doing
year over year and one of my favorite
examples
is this the case study project so one of
the priorities of
of our work here at stanford gsb is
creating an inclusive classroom and
learning experience
we feel like that's critical to our
mission of developing
purposeful and principled leaders so the
first step
was looking at all the case studies
that are taught in the core and finding
if there was anything we could learn
about
what was being taught and we discovered
that in some
written by us or written by other
business schools there are stereotypical
trends that may make us not see the
fullness of
the protagonists in the case studies so
we wrote this
up in a harvard business review piece
and what i love
about the report is it enabled us to not
have that be a one and done
we wrote it up it's done it helped us
build momentum so here's some of the
momentum
we built out of that one we started to
have
dialogues with faculty about these
stereotypical trends and sarah and her
colleagues developed a whole
training session on managing and
teaching these kinds of topics in the
classroom
the second outcome was that we trained
all of the case writers on this trend
and we have a commitment
that there are no stereotypical trends
in our case studies and
just this week i got to review one
that's being published now and
and to work with the team to take some
of those languages out
and the last thing it kind of
underpinned the training
that we do if this is how we
inadvertently think of people in
stereotypical ways
how can everyone our staff and our
students benefit from these insights so
i think we've moved the the report has
helped us move
from you know thinking very specifically
about
a project and turning it into maybe an
internal movement that we have that will
touch more and more people and
whenever we can we publish these
pieces in public magazines or outlets
like
harvard business review and fast company
because one of our commitments in the
report
is that we share these good ideas out
with the world
um one of my favorite ideas is if um
you do if we're lucky enough and you do
come to
stanford is one of the first things
you'll experience is something called
fitting in and standing out
like how can you both become part of our
culture
but not subsumed by it how can you also
contribute your unique
person so fitting in and standing out
and it was such a beautiful concept
well sarah and i decided to write up
this concept
in a fast company piece to share it more
broadly with the world so
part of what our dei report enables us
to do is
to build momentum around our ideas
and then to share them through the world
with um
free resources or publications that we
do so i'll stop there so
we can get on to your other questions
let me i will before you do that i
wanted to just say one more thing
um about the case project and some of
this work that we've been doing here
and i think this is really important and
it's partially because um
so many of us have connections to
faculty and staff
at our peer institutions but you know
not only are we trying to share
the work out there broadly we're also
specifically collaborating and working
with
our colleagues at our peer institutions
to do similar sorts of analyses of their
case studies and their class materials
and so
and it's really you know that's another
thing that's been very inspiring about
this work
and that is the the phone calls and the
zooms and the emails from
our friends at other uh business schools
who are saying hey how did you start
this project
and can you give us the templates you
use for identifying stereotypical
language
uh what's coming up next and so on and
so you know to
to sort of double click on something
laurie said about starting a
a little social movement not just
internally but starting it externally
too has been part of what's been
gratifying and i think important for
business education
writ large the two of you brought up
this
the notion of momentum and so and
how do you go from a moment or a project
and build some of that knowing that for
some companies or organizations there's
a lot of inertia
to stay still and this kind of comes is
also inspired by one of the questions in
the q a box from charlie about
you know roadblocks in the process uh
there's a lot of di efforts in place um
but there are resource constraints
and or privacy concerns like how do you
build momentum to be able to kind of
tackle some of those
yeah i'll start and then lori i'd love
to hear your response too and charlie
thanks for the question i think that's a
really great question because
we'd be lying if we said there weren't
some roadblocks along the way
and um you know will you identified
several of these
you know privacy concerns resource
constraints i'll also say
and this is always the case with dei
work in whatever
whether you're in non-profits
for-profits education
public sector is there going to be some
people who are
committed and passionate there is going
to be another set of people who could be
moved there but a little bit more
agnostic and then there are going to be
some resistors
and so part of what we need to do as we
do this work and part of what we focused
on doing
is um trying to move those who are
agnostic
into the passionate camp and trying to
um
figure out ways to reach in some way
some of the resistors and
we're not going to get them all we
aren't but importantly we do this by
framing what the issues are and why
they're important and
and by telling stories of the successes
that we have
and that the sort of proof of concept of
some of the work that we're doing
has been part of how i think we've
approached this
this work uh other constraints resource
constraints
there are always going to be resource
constraints but i also
like to think about constraints any
constraint you have is a source of
opportunity and innovation and so when
you you know think about what the
if you're running into a roadblock one
of the things that i often say is well
it's time to just
redefine the problem a little bit if
that's if we are not going to be able to
to to get over this roadblock we need to
redefine what the problem is and pivot
and think of a different way to to
approach it
and that usually works because usually
we can find
some silver lining and all of the little
bumps that we have along the way and
um and and and learn something from them
too
laurie did you want to chime in sure i
love
so much of what you said and and i just
want to add to what
to it so often with the idea of
how do you make an organization more
inclusive
it feels like you're boiling the ocean
and it might
be similar to thinking how do we become
more innovative
and if you stay in that big question
only it can almost be paralyzing to
think how can
how can i get going and you said some
things there about a proof point
and sometimes in our work we call it a
pilot
that instead of boiling the ocean
find where you can create change
work there to find out what works in
your organization
and then grow from that momentum as
opposed to really thinking
how can i boil the ocean and then you
said some
a really brilliant thing about
constraints it turns out if you try to
centralize a diversity and inclusion
budget in an organization
that budget can often be seen as
something that
can be cut but if instead you run the
pilots
in different organizations and have
those organizations
own the building of the momentum of
those pilots
you then dispersed the expertise
the budget and the momentum throughout
the organization instead of centralizing
it so
we see ourselves often as catalysts
to enable our well-intentioned and
passionate colleagues
to build the pilots to succe have
successes
that we can then spread throughout the
organization
versus feeling like oh we should boil
the ocean and
i think that's what's exciting this year
when we wrote the report
we had 74 entries
of positive change our colleagues have
promoted throughout the business school
so
that kind of positive change is very
hard to do if
sarah and i have to poke and and and
initiate everything centrally so i'm
optimistic i know there's a lot of work
to do but
that momentum is definitely happening um
where we are
yeah that really brings to mind like
that the concept of small wins
uh that you wrote about in the first dei
report and how that can be a catalyst
for change
yeah yeah and i think that's exactly i
think that's exactly right will
the small winds and telling the stories
about the small winds and
and showing people that this can work
and
inspiring people because you know as
charlie said there are going to be
roadblocks along the way and things that
we're going to
have to you know come up against but you
know
the the really good news is and and we
we're we have sort of a
it's almost a subtitle of the dei report
this year
which is about building momentum and how
um you know this this
this work has begun to spread and people
in the organization
are beginning to redefine how how they
approach their work with a different
lens and i think that's part of
what we um what we hope for in an
organizational change
um of any kind because it really is
about cultural change in the
organization
that could be the subtext of or the
subtitle for next year's ei report
adding lenses yes yes
lori is something that i'm i'm actually
really curious about like
as we were as you were coming up and
getting immersed in the gsb culture like
higher education
um an institution like the gsb
it's its own thing having a perspective
from kind of the corporate private side
what are some things that you anything
that stood out to you
things that you noticed um kind of
shifts in the way that you might have
had to approach
questions that you were asking yourself
that's such a great question will
because
culture really does matter context
really does matter and if i
came to gsb and said i want to create
change exactly
as i know i've helped create it in a
startup or
in a tech company and i probably
um would have incited more resistance
than
brought more people on board so that's
really great and um
think about a lot about mission and
values
because when there's a mission-driven
organization
that's pretty clear about what they
value
that's a great way to get to find how we
can move together
so when i came here what i was really
struck with
is that the mission already has
a commitment to purposeful and
principled leaders
and in my view i can't think of
anything more purposeful than creating
organizations where everyone
can be seen and thrive to produce better
outcomes for the organization
so starting there and having
conversations with colleagues about how
they contribute to it
exec ed does it in one way by
empowering leaders to advance themselves
our mba classrooms do it by empowering a
diversity of
leaders with the skills networks and
connections to be very successful
when they leave meeting people in for
example facilities
our facilities want to create
environments in which people could have
meaningful engagements and thrive so
wherever
i kind of reached out to people
having that common goal helped us find
directions we wanted to move in together
and
the last thing i'd say is you know most
of the work of diversity and inclusion
doesn't happen in big moments it happens
inside of relationships
and being able to carefully see people
for who they are
to value them to learn from them
that's something that works in every
organization so i think it's
caring deeply about relationships and
finding common
goals and directions we're moving
towards was how i entered my my work
here at gsb and
i have the most amazing network now of
colleagues like you will
and of course sarah that i feel so at
home with
i feel like we can do almost anything
together and so
and yeah it's been a good couple years
and then so i really like what you said
about like
change happens in like some of those
small moments context really matters
and this kind of ties back to some of
what um you were saying even to the
responsible for that
um where when there's roadblocks
kind of the evolution and kind of
focusing on the small areas
as a way to build that momentum so it
feels like there's
there's a lot there totally i mean you
know
i wanted to say yeah i was thinking of
the same thing will you know one of the
things that laurie said that i think is
really important um
and i want to give you some examples to
make it more concrete you know so lori
was talking about relationships and
getting to know and understand people
all over campus and so on and she
mentioned
like for example facilities that they
want to make this
a beautiful and welcoming place for all
of us
and you know one of the projects that
lori and i worked on
in the first or second year of our work
was thinking a little bit about things
like
the art that is hanging around the
campus and in particular
we targeted and thought about the
faculty building which is of course
the where the faculty offices are but
where us students would come and meet
with faculty for office hours or walk
through to grab a
cup of coffee these kinds of things and
the art was
not representative at all of what we
aspire to be
but it was really geared towards
thinking about the history of the school
and there's nothing wrong with thinking
about the history we need to honor the
history of the school
but what we wanted to do and what dean
levin wanted to do was to
to provide a more aspirational view of
the school and to show the school
as it is now as students are learning
now as faculty are teaching now as staff
and faculty are collaborating as
students are talking to alums and all of
that and so
we were really lucky to have some
talented photographers
as part of our marketing and
communications group who took
unbelievably beautiful pictures all over
campus
and um we've now been changing out all
of the art in the faculty
building and and that sounds like a very
in a sense it almost seems like well
that's a no-brainer and it kind of is a
no-brainer but there's actually research
behind this which is
known as ambient belonging research
which shows that when people
see the physical space around them and
feel like they're represented in the
space
and that they feel like it represents um
the
where how the space is now they feel
more comfortable
and so we're really that's just one
small example of thinking about
how our colleagues and facilities
uh engaged with this work another quick
one i'll give you just just um off off
the cuff is
you know when we started doing this work
and started talking about inclusion
our it group um you know had been
talking and thinking about how to make
our website and our documents more
inclusive and now they've got a big
project on
digital accessibility and making sure
that the content that we put out
is accessible to everyone not um and not
we're not putting up any um any any
kinds of hurdles so that people can't
access our content so
so by bringing this dei lens to all of
the work we do and by connecting to
colleagues and
and um and bringing people um
uh into this project with us and finding
small wins and redefining the work
that's how we make cultural change yeah
you
ch change is a common theme here and
it's almost
sometimes it feels like there might be a
tension
between honoring tradition and history
versus
kind of understanding recognizing and
embracing the evolution of organization
so it's almost like
how do you navigate that any tips on how
do you navigate that
and how do you have conversations with
folks who might
lean more towards this was our history
so that should be
you know how we need to be like any tips
on approaching those
dialogue yeah that's such a great
question well it's such a good question
and by the way this
is beyond even diversity equity and
inclusion it's in in all of
all of our work we'll be doing this and
i think that um
you know one of the the things that i
think is really important
in all of this work is um is is asking
people to take the perspective of others
um and to step into the shoes of others
and when you
say to somebody who may be you know a
proponent of keeping all of the old
history art up and by the way we found
homes for the old artwork and so on too
it wasn't like we
you know we're rewriting history we just
found different places for them
and but but when you say to people well
do you understand and i i said this to
some of them i said
you understand as one of the you know
the few
senior women faculty i would like to see
more women represented in
these photos because it makes me feel
excluded as soon as you
ask them to take your perspective they
kind of begin to get it and say oh
okay and if you say to them hey have you
ever felt excluded or like you didn't
belong somewhere
it turns out there's a lot of
psychological research on on belonging
and how it is hardwired into us as human
beings and when you sort of point that
out and say do you remember when you
didn't feel like you belonged
well that's kind of how i feel when all
there are pictures of
um you know the founding fathers and
they were all fathers of this school and
then they kind of say oh
oh i value you as a colleague and and i
i don't want you to feel hurt
and then they begin to see how we can
change things so that's usually asking
people to take perspective i think
and particularly in an academic
environment pointing to the research on
some of this
i noticed in chat that joanna had put in
a
link to spark tools some of um i was
talking about ambient belonging and some
of the
other research on just generally
thinking about belonging is available
there for free if people are interested
in engaging with those so thanks joanna
for putting that
in the chat
if i can i just want to add one thing
that's dovetails and
and what you said sarah is there's
really interesting to think about the
question of authenticity
i think this gets at what you're saying
will is it authentic of us
to to be here and move towards there are
you forcing
me in a direction and the interesting
thing about
authenticity is it actually expands over
time
so for example before business school it
wasn't very authentic of me or i didn't
even know what
net present value meant right or i
didn't know
what it meant to ask about certain
things in organizations
and over time it's become very
comfortable and natural for me
to think and ask those questions so
authenticity actually expands over time
and who we know ourselves to be
will expand over time both as an
individual
and an organization so how do we make
room
for that expansion ex instead of
viewing it as you know detracting from
or
forcing us in a direction so i often
talk about expansion which is very
natural
so what feels natural today did not feel
natural 10 years ago
and i'm excited to think about what's
going to feel natural 10 years from now
so
sometimes i have this authenticity
conversation with people because
it's not a fixed way of being it's a
gross way of being and how can we all
grow into
a newer and more expansive version of
ourselves
versus saying it's diminishing who we
are and where we came from
yeah it's interesting to talk about the
different ways
to approach this besides kind of a
monetary justification we have a
question
um a comment from jimmy who is talking
about sometimes
you know that's the way to get people's
attention but
there are other types of value that can
be derived out of
out of this so like that concept of
expansion and growth
um as individuals and teams is actually
like a really interesting concept and
juxtaposition with that
yeah yeah i like that observation yes
sorry i like that observation a lot
because i think that that's
that's exactly right we need to think
about what this does for
us as individuals and for organizations
and how
we um just without thinking about just
you know the monetary value how we can
think about the um
the value we add lori i cut you off i'm
so sorry
no we we have kind of a mind melt so it
was funny when
sarah and i were working on a document
we happened to be in there at the same
time even though we could have been
there any hour of the day so sarah and i
often end up
having similar thoughts so i actually
enjoy um when we when we do that and
one thing i just wanted to add i love
this point there's different
ways into valuing diversity and
inclusion
and one way that is very common in
silicon valley
is to value innovation and
people often can get that part of the
value of innovation is
bringing together different experiences
knowledges and heuristics or way ways we
learn
to create novel connections between all
of our ideas
to spark an innovation so
to your point sometimes people see the
monetary value like
we're not going to be able to hire the
best if we're not including everyone
we're not going to have the best returns
others will
value innovation that we want to bring
these diverse perspectives together
and some will think about kind of go to
market reasons like
what what how can we know our consumers
of the future
if we ourselves don't have
representation on our teams of
different kinds of people so i often say
i'm agnostic or open to how you
enter the dei space i'm really committed
that we keep you here
and you see that this will fuel what
what you're up to
oh i love that like agnostic for how how
someone enters into this space
and then oh i'm really excited sorry
i don't know if you could tell but like
so a lot of the insights you're
providing i think are
so real to the here and now the moment
of
kind of 2020 um kind of
the rise and renewed awareness of social
justice issues in
many different ways and how that's
almost forced
in some sense an evolution in the way we
think about this work dei
um what does that mean for our students
and community can you talk a little bit
about
from your vantage point as kind of
overseeing this effort at the gsb how
2020 has impacted that sure i'll begin
and then i'll invite laurie to jump in
if she if
she wants uh so yes 2020 well
i i don't need to even you know i can
say unprecedent
as unprecedented i can say it was kind
of a dumpster fire i can say all kinds
of things about 2020.
but what what's happened here um you
know you know
going back to something we said earlier
about constraints and roadblocks being
opportunities and so on
i i i think that laurie and i and
certainly will and many of our
colleagues who work on
diversity equity and inclusion try to
take a positive and optimistic view
on our work because i think it's it's
necessary but 2020
as we all know was has been a very very
tough year for all of the reasons that
we know but certainly
i'll focus on i'm not going to talk
about the pandemic and i'm not going to
talk about economic and uncertainty i'm
not going to talk about online learning
i'm not going to talk about all that
but let's just talk about um the the
brutal murder of george floyd
and the ensuing wave of protest that
happened in this country
and what that protest did which i think
is
that wave of protest did which i think
is important to what we do here but
other organizations
was it allowed um it allowed
a new conversation to come into
organizations and to
add as an important corrective to
diversity equity and inclusion efforts
and
and what that did and what that meant to
us here at the gsb
was that we recognized that our efforts
to date
had not done as much as as they should
with respect to race and thinking about
systemic racism and thinking about
racial injustice
both in terms of how we want to view our
own community but also
how we want to train our students as
they go out to lead organizations
and so what this led us to do and this
took place um
you know mostly in june and july of this
year
was to spend a lot of time you know i
said at the beginning that when we
started the first diversity equity and
inclusion report
i spent a lot of time and then brought
others into the fold of listening
and learning and listening and learning
and we accelerated that again and had
another wave
of discussions and conversations with
our our
black alums our black students allies of
our
black alums and blacks students black
staff and allies
and faculty and allies and we spent a
lot of time
learning and understanding and listening
to
um their stories and listening to what
they
um were asking for for um for
the black community from the gsb and
that led us to
uh in july 2020 we published our action
plan for racial equity
which we can give you the link for that
on the website and then
as follow-up i hope that we'll be able
to send you in about
three weeks the new dei report which has
our first update on
how we've been doing on the action plan
for racial equity
but very briefly what we promised to do
in the action plan
for racial equity was um to think about
four
kind of categories of work that we were
committing to
and the first is increasing
representation
and so you know part of what we have
been doing and engaging in
for for many years is trying to get the
most representative and diverse class
that we can
and will and his colleagues have been
doing an amazing job at that but we
wanted to think about other things that
we could be doing to increase
representation not just in mba
but also in the phd program msx program
and also in our executive
education programs and so that's one
piece of what we've been doing
and also on the faculty side and the
staff side and taking to task how we
might be able to
um increase diversity of our community
so
one of the things that is going on at
the gsb right now
is that the and not the jsp i'm sorry at
stanford but we are actively part
of this is um that the provost of
stanford
uh created ten new lines ten new faculty
lines
for people who study race in america
and so we are right now at the gsb all
of the areas are
looking and searching in this area so
that we can
um you know bring more scholars to
campus who focus
specifically on race in america in our
case in the gsb
it will be race and business primarily
that's one thing the second bucket is
working more we've already talked a
little bit about belonging and a culture
of belonging and inclusion and belonging
and so we've been working on that as
well that's the second bucket
and so we've been coming up with a
number of different ways in which we can
do this from thinking about class
materials we've talked about case
studies but we're also
we have an initiative that to to write
case studies this year
on underrepresented minorities
especially black
leaders and the last time i checked with
the case writing operation
there were six new cases on black
leaders that are
underway so that's one example and of
thinking about how to build a culture of
inclusion in the classroom
and then making positive change beyond
the gsb
is the third kind of category that we've
promised in the action plan for racial
equity
and we've done a number of different
things in this area for example
senior associate dean and professor
brian lowery
ran a class called leadership for
society race power
um racing power and has turned that into
a podcast so we can give you a link to
hear some of those discussions i mean
these were
sort of a speaker series on race and
power in
america um i created with a colleague
maggie neal
and another colleague hannah yanao an
anti-racism
an allyship seven-day journey it's kind
of a
seven days of study and reflection
and commitment to action around
anti-racism and allyship
um a lot of other things that we've been
doing and you can read about this in the
upcoming dei report
and then finally and really importantly
and i saw a question in the question and
answers about this too
that i wanted to touch on is how we're
going to hold ourselves accountable to
the action plan
for racial equity and we're in the
process right now of building a dei
council and we are lori and i
will be meeting soon to complete with
another one of our colleagues to
complete our review
of mba students who have applied for the
slots on
the dei council also phd students and
then we'll also have staff and faculty
as well on that
um and then we've also committed to
certain roles on
at the at the gsb which we will be
actively trying to fill there's one for
example
um that is i i can't announce it quite
yet but we're very close to filling
which is
um a director of diverse alumni
communities
which will be in the alumni relations
organization so there's a lot going on
in the action plan for racial equity
but i would say will to your original
question how did 2020 change what we are
doing
we doubled down on our efforts
specifically on thinking about race
racial justice
systemic racism and eliminating systemic
racism to the extent that we can and the
power that we
we have as an institution and as
individuals
you mentioned allyship and many of the
different actions we're taking in the
many
different spaces that make up the gsb i
mean oftentimes we just think about the
student body
as kind of the school whereas it's this
whole
like universe of things and people that
make it
run and make it the special place it is
um
this is one of our earlier questions
here like what are some different ways
that you've seen
students get involved in this effort how
can people get involved once they're
here
you just mentioned the dei council but
that's just one of
multiple spaces that kind of we've seen
students
um yeah absolutely i'll take a stab and
then i hope youtube will
will add on because the short answer is
and i that i want i
flag that as one of the things the dei
council but um the diversity committee
is another
area in which a lot of our passionate
students have um
have have come to to to
to to be to i don't want to say work but
it but there's obviously a lot of work
around diversity equity and inclusion
amongst the student bodies
and um so that's one area and then we
also have a number of identity
groups um on campus and a number of our
students who
are interested in diversity equity and
inclusion are also part of an active
in the identity group space um and then
i'll
also say that and this has been really
gratifying for me and
and i know lori too when we write the
diversity equity and inclusion report
we ask for feedback and we ask for
feedback in the way of
hey you know can you suggest some things
that are going on amongst the student
groups the student bodies that you would
like us to include but then
also would you help us to you know read
this and and
look take a look at the language are we
getting this right or are we
somehow inadvertently not being
inclusive in our language
and so that's another way that we that
students have been involved in the work
that we are doing
um lori and will others there's a lot
more i'm sure
well one of my favorites is the the
classes that
students can take once they're at gsb
and
and
some of them i've been fortunate enough
to be a guest and so i've gotten to take
a peek inside of
one of those that i love is called
equity by design which takes place in a
lab
so it's looking at all the questions
you're asking
and getting the research getting the
insights and then creating your own
pathways
to see what you might do to design when
you're a leader in an organization so
there's
a number of classes you can take there's
also
interestingly because many groups are
looking at how they can bring this
diversity equity and inclusion lens to
the work they're doing
for example our center for
entrepreneurial studies
they are looking at how they can bring
dei
as a criteria for thinking about
investing in organizations what would
that look like
so students who are interested in
entrepreneurship
can also look at how to bring a dei lens
into how they evaluate organizations
um i love the center for social
innovation as well
thinking about how um i think 94
of our students participated in some way
with cesis our center for social
innovation so how can you contribute to
your own leadership development
by working with or taking a class with
and one of our centers
that has as part of its lens diversity
equity inclusion and so bring
that lens to the work you're doing and
will i know you're also
um fostering a lot of of work around
that as well
yeah i one of the conversations that the
students are having that i find
so invigorating and inspiring is
the increased sensitivity and awareness
about intersectionality
what does that mean for kind of the way
we move through space
what does that mean for the way that the
world
influences and impacts our own
experience
and then kind of hand in hand with that
is allyship
and how do we kind of be there with
and for those you know in our community
and that comes to one of the questions
actually using that as a segway to one
of the questions so maybe get your
thoughts on
um how can students balance the interest
to engage or any individual for that
matter
as an ally with groups that are outside
of their identity
without quote intruding or taking away
from the experience
of those who do identify with that
particular group
um and this is a question from missy out
there any tips there
thanks missy i'll take one stab and then
gloria it looks like lori was about
lauren do you want to go first this time
okay i'll take one step
i think this is such an important and
deep question
missy because this is this is such a
there's such a tricky and delicate
balance but you know what
and also to share from my own experience
when part of the reason that we
created the anti-racism and allyship
journey
um was that we were um
inspired and also humbled by
the fact that during that period the
beginning you know
that i've already made reference to
after the killing of george floyd
and during the black lives matter
protest all of our black colleagues
and were being asked to
contribute to a panel or come and talk
to this group
or create this or come educate us
on something and we were humbled and
inspired by what they were doing but
also understanding
that this was an identity tax on
on them and so what we wanted to do was
to try to create something
as academics and it's an academic you
know the research behind the
anti-racism and allyship journey comes
from academics we wanted to do that
to as a way to try not to intrude on the
space
do it with their blessing but
understanding that we were doing this as
allies and we have gotten you know
incredibly
positive feedback about that because it
was both an act of allyship
and so my point really here and this is
speaking from experience
less from you know giving the the
playbook for how to do this
was that humility is part of what is key
i think in in when we are trying to act
as allies and being sure that
when we act as an ally we're not there
to teach we're not there to intrude
we're there to listen and we're there to
help
and importantly we're there to do
something right
there's one of the things that we talk a
lot about in the anti-racism and
allyship journey
is how to avoid performative allyship or
optical allyship
because i think that you know most will
agree
that you know to really be an ally
requires action
and so you know we've sort of you know
tried to preach that
but i think missy to your could really
drill down on your question i think it
requires humility
it requires listening and it requires
ability to step back
um and um and say you're sorry if you
have moved too far into somebody's space
where you're not wanted
and lori
i i love what you said sarah and i um
to your point even the way you framed
the question
missy shows your deep understanding of
this topic
that you wouldn't want to go in and
intrude so i just
really appreciate as you said sarah how
you framed the question
and everything sarah said and the one
thing i'd add is
um have that relationship develop going
back to relationships
to when where you can get feedback so
i'll just give one small example we were
creating what we call a listening
session for
the staff at the business school where
we
had people sign up if they wanted to
participate not in a training
but a space where you could share your
experiences
about what's happening um about
anti-racism and how
you know how how you might want to take
action
and i was invited to help kick that off
and i wanted to make sure that how i
did that really worked as an ally and
not as someone who knows or someone who
was trying to put my
own perspective on so i made sure that i
incorporated into our planning some time
to just say
if i say this how does that land for you
um
what else is missing what do you need me
to say so i think
back to relationships having trusted um
relationships that help you see where
your allyship's not working
or how to improve it or to say oh that
did work
um has been important for me to develop
myself
because if i only as you said sarah come
from my own perspective
i might get it wrong but if i have the
ability or humility to ask for
support in that together we can craft
how allyship looks versus um coming at
it as
you know from two to two separate sides
of the equation
yeah and you mentioned both of you
mentioned like humility approaching this
with a sense of like
sensitivity to those around you um
and i think there is some recognition in
this work
that when we like because we're trying
there's always going to be the potential
to
fail to step in it to maybe accidentally
um kind of do something that lands
kind of differently than you intended
and i think it's that agency and being
proactive about
taking ownership and responsibility
learning from those instances
recognizing and acknowledging when you
um when you've stepped in it basically
um that really helps in that and i think
that's something uh frank
angelia um i think that's where for your
question here about like
even with good intentions an initiative
might not be executed well or end up
taking a step back rather than forward
i think the scaling of taking
responsibility whether it's with an
individual or
as a leader of initiative i think that
spirit stays the same so i
that's a theme that i've i've kind of
pulled from what sarah and laura were
talking about that i think might be
helpful here okay
we are wrapping up but i think this
might actually be a
time so we're talking about the approach
to the dei report
the evolution how do we think about
shifting
and evolving the way we think and act
taking responsibility for some of those
actions and so as folks from here
continue to go on into the their lives
beyond
are there any other of these small
actions
or um things that people can incorporate
into their everyday knowing kind of that
spirit of small wins
can like result in some like pretty like
meaningful change
i can take a stab first um if if that's
okay
i i love what you said will because it's
not that we have to
have our organizations change only we
can become
a role model of what change looks like
and i
often find that asking new questions
is one way that i can create change so
sometimes for example
i might be critical of a behavior like
oh that just didn't seem professional
to me and instead of just moving into
that
and trying to correct the behavior
sometimes i've stopped myself and asked
well why am i being so critical here
because
sometimes the behavior is just fine
the reaction i'm having might be based
on stereotypes or bias
so one thing is to ask new questions why
are you criticizing or
how did you make that decision did you
make that decision because you're
comfortable with the way things are
and you don't want to try something new
so for example
what if you picked different criteria
for
offering someone a really great
opportunity instead of going with the
person who has all the experience
maybe the question is for whom would
this opportunity make a big difference
and then commit yourself to helping them
grow into it so
when action i think everyone can take is
to ask new questions
why are you criticizing something why
are you giving an opportunity
to someone and then seeing if you can
come up with a way
to develop your diversity equity
inclusion lens
to come up with different answers to the
new questions that you're asking
sarah i don't know if you have other
small wins people can take
absolutely love that i love it love it
love it because
um it really is and by asking those
questions
you're you are doing two things which
are part of our broader gsb leadership
model which should you come here you
will hear a lot about
and but by asking questions of yourself
and asking questions of others
you're essentially enacting
self-awareness
and perspective taking which are two
which are two pieces of
our leadership model that we teach here
and that we
hope people will engage with and so by
asking questions we're doing both of
those
the other thing that i'll say on top of
that i think
is the is is something that we can all
do and we haven't really talked about
this um
although it's part of allyship and i saw
in the questions that somebody mentioned
the word accomplice what are you know
what what's
what how can we become accomplices and
that's really what i mean when i say
allyship should be an action too the
other thing that i would sort of a
very small thing you can do and i'm
going to quote my friend lori here
um you can engage in micro sponsorship
micro sponsorship it's a great term the
in the literature
on mentorship versus sponsorship there's
a difference and these are different
roles and when we sponsor somebody
we are getting behind them and we are
using our networks and we're essentially
putting our
neck out for them and that can be scary
scot sponsorship can be very very scary
because it's a big lift and because your
own reputation is on the line
so how do you think about micro
sponsorship as something that
is before sponsorship this big big
sponsorship
so thinking about ways for example to
elevate people
in uh in in meetings and in
conversations by
um making sure you amplify something
that they've said
which maybe was looked over that's one
example
another example is one that lori just
gave and her wonderful answer to this
question
which was thinking about changing the
criteria a little bit so
rather than going for the person who's
maybe the most experienced
who's this for whom will this
opportunity
have the biggest payoff as a different
criteria to think about it
so thinking about micro sponsorship as a
way that you can
intervene in situations which may be
sub-optimal
you can think about ways that
micro-sponsorship can be
an anecdote to microaggressions and
sub-optimal everyday interactions that
we may have
and they're again small things that you
can do
which can have an outsized impact on
the lives of the people around you and
the culture that you
inhabit yeah and so as we
do this work how do we know we're headed
in the right direction how do we know
we're making progress are there ways to
measure what are do you have any
thoughts on
how we might be able to think or
communicate around those topics
i'll say a couple of things one is
mischievous
and that is we know we're we know we're
doing something right if
um if some people are taking notice and
maybe you know
complaining a little i know the
mischievous way i know that when
somebody is
making a little complaint we're probably
doing something right one of the
recalcitrant folks
um but in terms of measuring too that's
part of what we want to do with the dei
report
is that we want to have an annual metric
on a number of different
characteristics and so some for just
very quickly for example
one of the things that we've been
collecting data on are guest speakers
and classes
and we one of the wonderful things about
the gsb
is that our faculty and our lecturers
have an expanded network of unbelievable
leaders who come and speak in classes
and
maybe they're a protagonist in the case
study but they come in and share their
experience
on whatever the lesson is and one
we've been able to collect data on those
individuals
and up until this point we've only
gotten
gender data but we're now experimenting
with and so in the new dei report the
2021
at least for one set of those visitors
we
we piloted we tried out how many people
would respond if we sent a survey to
them and asked
about other identities and so on we had
an 80
response rate on that survey that's a
pilot so we'll
we'll we will use that in this year's
dei report
and then be able to expand that to all
of the visitors to campus
and so by doing this you know this is
one way we can measure our progress over
time
and another way that we can inspire uh
change
by showing oh gee look at this um
particular group and or class you had a
less diverse
you know set of guest speakers than this
other class and so it's a way to both
inspire change but also
measure how we're doing that's just one
example
thank you so much we are at the top of
the hour i just want to thank
the both of you for sharing time and
space with us today
that was incredible i also want to thank
you for all of the work that you've been
leading
at the gsb we would not be where we are
today without you
and everything you do inspires us to
continue with those small wins
so for everybody who's joined us i hope
you go
out think of those little ways that you
might be able to ask
questions differently build on the
relationships that are around you
and maybe try a pilot or two or three
the measurement might be different the
way you approach it might be different
but in
everything there's an opportunity to
learn grow and kind of
enhance the realm and the world around
us so with that
thank you again for joining us today if
you have any questions at all please
feel free to reach out at the mba
admissions office
we have one more session later this
afternoon featuring assistant dean of
mba admissions
and financial aid kristin moss and then
closing out this week
with one more faculty insights with
huggy rao uh we
where we'll have a very special guest so
hopefully we'll see you there and until
then stay
safe and i hope our paths cross again
soon goodbye